foreign
so I have been in the studio all day today
it is getting late but I have stuck with it
here because I am super excited about this
next lecture uh we're going to start solving
these generic systems of equations
x dot equals ax using eigenvalues
and eigenvectors so I'll just put that up
solving x dot equals ax with eigenvalues
and eigenvectors eigenvectors and I'd say this
is one of the culminations of all of kind of
introductory applied math linear algebra
and differential equations is going to be
covered in this and the next two lectures where
we really break down how to solve Matrix Systems
of differential equations using eigenvalues and
eigenvectors specifically I am actually going to
derive the eigenvalue and eigenvector equation as
a necessary coordinate transformation to simplify
this differential equation so this lecture is
going to end on kind of deriving from scratch
the equation from which we obtain eigenvalues
and eigenvectors specifically to solve this
this system okay so I'm going to write out the
objective I'm going to solve a simple case and
then we're going to jump into eigenvalues and
eigenvectors so we basically want to solve we want
to solve a generic system of
equations a general General
system of ordinary differential equations
x dot equals ax system of equations
equations uh and specifically X is a vector
of States now there are multiple you know X1
X2 X3 X4 multiple components of this Vector x
a is a matrix and this is a system of coupled
first order linear ordinary differential equations
first order because we only have one derivative in
time coupled because presumably these derivatives
depend on all of the other states in this Vector X
and linearly linear because this derivative
x dot is a linear combination of the states
in X that's literally what a matrix times a
vector means that's a linear combination okay
um and so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to start off with the simplest possible case
where this a matrix is diagonal meaning that the
Dynamics are decoupled okay so uh kind of case one
case one is where what we have what
we call decoupled Dynamics decoupled
decoupled Dynamics I'll tell you what that
means so remember when we had um kind of our
first example of a differential equation x dot
equals Lambda X the example we introduced was the
population of bunnies and Bunny populations grow
exponentially what I mean by decoupled Dynamics is
going to be let's say that the state X refers to
the populations of different animals but they are
kind of in a zoo so they're each cordoned off into
different zones and so that they don't interact
that's what I mean by decoupled so we're going to
have the populations of like bunnies and wolves
tools and Antelope and so I'm going to have a
state Vector with multiple populations and they're
each going to behave linearly but they're only
going to depend on themselves they're not going
to be coupled yet so I like to call this kind of
you know my example I think about is a different
animals in a zoo and it's a zoo that's big enough
where they can grow exponentially it's kind of
like a Hilbert's zoo or something like that
okay so the populations are separate that's
the key things that the populations are separate
and so I'm going to write down this differential
equation so we have let's say our state Vector X
has a bunch of components X1 X2 dot dot dot all
the way to X N let's say I have n animals in N
different zones in this zoo and I'm taking D DT
of this state Vector that's just this is just
x dot where X is a big Vector containing all of
these components and we're going to say that this
equals in the case of decoupled Dynamics this is
again a matrix a times X1 X2 dot dot dot xn but
now what we're going to have is that this is going
to be a diagonal matrix so X1 dot is only going to
be a function of X1 we're going to call that let's
say you know Lambda 1 0 dot dot dot zero the
second animal let's say X1 or bunny population
let's call that our wolves X2 dot is only going to
be a function of X2 because they live in their own
you know room in this big Zoo so they actually
are not interacting with the bunnies so they
have no influence X1 has no influence on on X2
X2 dot is only equal to uh com to a number times
X2 we're going to call that number Lambda 2. so
X2 dot equals Lambda 2 x 2 and that's the only
uh these are decoupled so you know the wolves are
alone the bunnies are alone dot dot dot it's very
lonely I actually think they're fine with uh
you know all the bunnies together and then um
kind of every term is like this and now the X
N Dynamics the nth population whatever uh only
depends on the X N population with this Lambda n
proportionality so this is really really simple
um in some case I didn't even need to write this
as a system of differential equations in a matrix
form I could have literally just written this as
so before I forget I'm going to call this Matrix
D because it's diagonal and decoupled okay so
this is a special case of an a matrix where it's
diagonal and decoupled I didn't even have to
write it like this I could have literally just
written down you know X One Dot equals Lambda
1 x 1 x 2 dot equals Lambda 2 x 2 dot dot dot
x n dot equals Lambda n x n and of course we
already know the solution of this we can just
solve them each independently we could say that
X 1 at time T is e to the Lambda 1 T times X1
my initial condition X1 naught and x 2
at time T is equal to e to the Lambda 2 t
times that initial wolf population X2 knot all the
way down to xn at time T equals e to the Lambda
n t times x n not the initial population
of that nth uh you know animal population
and so these are really easy
because my Dynamics are decoupled
it's almost trivial for me to solve the system of
equations and if I like I can write this solution
again in Matrix form I can just say you know this
is um X 1 x 2 dot dot dot x n this big Vector X
at time T is equal to and now I have a diagonal
matrix of of exponentials I have e to the Lambda
1 t 0 dot dot dot zero I have zero e to the
Lambda 2 T dot dot dot zero so this should be
pretty you know intuitive at this point zero zero
e to the Lambda n t times my initial conditions
times you know X1 X2 dot dot dot X and this
Vector evaluated at Time Zero and so this is
really really simple this uh if this Matrix here
was d a diagonal matrix then this Matrix here is
e to the diagonal matrix T okay it's literally
a diagonal matrix where I exponentiate all of
the diagonal elements times T this is e to the
D T I haven't defined what a matrix exponential
is yet I'll Define that in a couple of lectures
it's really easy you literally take the Taylor
series for you know e to the X and you just plug
in a matrix for x and you work it out that's how
you take Matrix exponentials and this is what you
get for decoupled Dynamics okay so this is really
really really easy to solve my system of equations
x dot equals ax if a is a diagonal matrix d
good so I hope I've convinced you that that's
really really easy okay this is the full solution
well they're not going to be nice and diagonal
like this you know you're not going to be dealing
with animals in a zoo you're going to be dealing
with the populations of bunnies and wolves and
Antelope in the wild and they're not going to be
separated they're going to be interacting with
each other so there's going to be cross terms in
this Matrix and in general a is not going to be
diagonal it's going to be a full gnarly Matrix
and it's not going to be easy to solve it like
this okay and so that's where eigenvalues and
eigenvectors are going to come in what we're
going to try to do is we are going to try to find
a coordinate transformation that turns this system
into a diagonal decoupled system I'm going to
erase this and then write that out one second
okay so we now know that it's easy to solve
these Matrix systems of equations if the Matrix
a relating all of my derivatives to all of my
States is diagonal and decoupled so now the
objective here is going to be for this generic
system for a general system for a general system
x dot equals a x what we're going to try
to do we want a change of coordinates we
want a new coordinate system
or a change of coordinates
a change of coordinates and I'm
going to write this as X equals t
times Z so T is going to be a matrix an invertible
Matrix a matrix that has non-zero determinant so
you can compute its inverse so I can go
from X to Z or Z to X by multiplying by
The Matrix t or its inverse so I want a change
of coordinates into a new coordinate system Z
that diagonalizes my ordinary
differential equation that
diagonalizes diagonalizes
diagonalizes my ode
specifically what I want in this
z-coordinate system I want Z Dot
to equal a diagonal decoupled matrix times Z
Okay, that's my entire objective now: If I have a generic system -- if someone hands me a system, and they say"Hey Steve, can you model this system?"
I'm going to first try to find a coordinate transformation
T that goes back and forth from
from x coordinates into a z coordinate system
where in this coordinate system my dynamics are
decoupled and diagonal, because here I could
easily solve this. We know how to solve this:
"z" as a function of time, is e^Dt times my initial conditions.
I know howto solve this.
This is easy to solve... we justdid it.  So now I'm going to try to find thiscoordinate transformation that diagonalizes mysystem.
Specifically we're going to dothis and we're going to derive the eigenvalueand eigenvector equation.
So I'm going to take the time derivative of both sides of this thing
maybe I'll go orange here for a minute
So I'm going to take the time derivative of both sides
and I'm going to take T z-dot, that equals x-dot
and x-dot equals Ax, so that equals A x
and so that implies that T z-dot = Ax
and specifically x equals Tz so here I can
plug it in... I'm trying to get an equation for z...
So I can basically say that T z-dot=Ax and that's A * T * z this equals
A * T * z and now we'll remember to
put all of these as matrices and vectors... so big
capital letters generally I use to mean matrices...
so A and T are matrices. z and x are vectors
that's my the state of my system x, and z is the
state of my system in some different coordinate
system... and I'll tell you what I mean by a
different coordinate system in a minute.
So now this is starting to get somewhere... now we have
a differential equation only in z but I have this
pesky T out here so I'm going to try to invert
this T and and multiply on both sides by that
so that gives me z-dot=T^ A T z
and remember I'm specifically trying to find this matrix T...
that's what I mean by a coordinate transformation, it's
just a matrix T... linear coordinate transformations
are matrix multiplication, that's what linear
algebra tells us, and so specifically I'm trying
to find a T matrix so that this quantity here is
a diagonal matrix, so that z-dot equals this stuff
here is diagonal times z. And so specifically
we can write this pretty simply: we want
We want a T matrix so that
T-inverse A T equals this
diagonal matrix... okay that's what we want.
Okay writing all these double under
bars is getting a little tedious but I'm going
to stick with it because I think it's important.
So we want a T so that this is true. We had this
system, we want to find a coordinate transformation
that diagonalizes our dynamics and if we had a T
so that T-inverse A T equals the diagonal
matrix we've done it. And so the last
step is actually very simple. The last
step here is: I'm just going to multiply both sides
again on the left by T to kill
this T -inverse and so that is going to give me
AT=TD.  I multiplied the left by T on both
sides so I get AT=TD. These are matrices.
This is the eigenvalue and eigenvector equation.
T his is the this is the eigenvalue equation
I'm going to put some big exclamation
marks because this is a huge deal.
Literally the diagonal elements of D are the eigenvaluesof A.
And the columns of T are the eigenvectors of A.
of a okay D is a matrix a is a matrix so I haven't
shown you how to solve for T and D that's a whole
another lecture I'm going to do that next we're
going to we're going to show how for a specific
a matrix we can find these eigenvalues
in D and the eigenvectors in t but this
is the equation the equation that I'm solving
for T is so that my Dynamics become diagonal
those T are the eigenvectors of a that's exactly
what this means this is the eigenvalue eigenvector
equation so for me I always found it very
counterintuitive that you take a linear algebra
class and they write down all this abstract kind
of algebra and they write down here's what an
eigenvalue and eigenvector is without motivating
it for me this is why we care about eigenvalues
and eigenvectors in the first place this is
why I care about eigenvalues and eigenvectors
because eigenvectors of a matrix change are
a change of coordinates so that it becomes
diagonal these eigenvectors provide a change of
coordinates in these eigenvector coordinates my
Dynamics are diagonal that's huge that means I
can solve any linear system of equations okay so
I'm almost done I think what I'm going to do now
is I'm literally going to draw a picture of this
for you so I'm going to say I'm going to draw
a picture of this eigenvalue equation and then
I'm going to you know end this lecture and in the
next lecture we're going to figure out how do you
compute these things and then how do you use these
T's and D's specifically to solve this equation
and then to go back and write it in terms of my
original x coordinates which is where you know I
probably measured things and where I actually care
about things Okay so so um I have my a matrix here
I'm just going to draw it as a big Square
matrix it's an N by n Matrix okay that's a
this T Matrix has columns you know T1 T2 dot dot
dot all the way up to TN these are column vectors
where each column vector is an
eigenvector of a and this is equaling
now I maybe Drew this just a tiny tiny
tiny bit too tall that's going to be a
problem okay these are the eigenvectors of
a let's give myself a little more room here
so a times t equals T times d
so this is going to equal again T1 T2 dot dot dot
all the way up to T N this is again my T Matrix
times D my my diagonal matrix okay and my
diagonal matrix again just had these these
lambdas these eigenvalues um sometimes in
my notes I call them D1 D2 D3 I'm here I'm
just going to call them Lambda 1 Lambda
2 Lambda 1 Lambda 2 dot dot dot Lambda n
zeros everywhere else and here's
what I want to point out is that
if I take this
um a column of this so if I want to multiply this
matrix by this Matrix what I do is I take the
First Column of D and I kind of knock it over
on its side and multiply it by every row of t
that's my first column then I take the second
column of d i knock it over on its side and I
multiply it by all of the rows of T that's my
second column and so on and so forth but if you
take let's say this Lambda 2 you know this column
here and I knock it over on its side and multiply
it because it's zeros everywhere else it's only
going to multiply the t2 eigenvector so this is
a very useful property of this diagonal
matrix this literally is going to equal
Lambda 1 T1 that vector Lambda 2 T2
that Vector dot dot dot Lambda n t n
that Vector okay and so what we're basically
going to find is that a times T1 is going to
equal Lambda 1 t 1. a times T2 the second
column of this product is going to equal
Lambda 2 T2 and so on and so forth I'm going
to get a bunch of of equations that look like a
times T equals Lambda times T okay like for the
kth eigenvector and the kth eigenvalue this is
going to be true okay so you can write it in this
Matrix system of equations or you can write it for
a specific eigenvector t or eigenvalue Lambda
now here TK is just a a single eigenvector
corresponding to that particular eigenvalue these
come in pairs is what I'm trying to say okay let's
take a big step back uh we want to solve these
systems generically they are not going to be
diagonal we know that we like diagonal systems
because they're easy to solve but generically
they're not going to be diagonal so we try to
find a coordinate transformation t a matrix T
that can map me into a new coordinate system like
literally you know Z is going to equal T inverse
of X so I can go from X to this new coordinate
system Z so that Z has diagonal decoupled Dynamics
so it's easy to solve my Dynamics in z now if I
go through some algebra we find that this is the
condition so if Z dot these are the Dynamics
in my Z coordinates and so if I want these to
be diagonal then this has to be true and I can
rewrite that in terms of my eigenvalue equation
so this is the equation I solve to get that
eigenvector coordinate transformation T that
diagonalizes my Matrix a and given that we're
going to be able to solve generic systems that
are really nasty in terms of easy easy easy
linear algebra okay and that's all coming up
next in the next lecture I'm going to show
you how do you actually compute eigenvalues
and eigenvectors and in the lecture after that
I'm going to show you how do you use that to
actually solve these differential equations
that we want all right thank you foreign